qui tombaient du ciel comme il dit il a
voulu faire plaisir à tout le monde et
il a lâché en à peine une semaine sept
cent cinquante mille euros
à tout
payer il faut à huile et albin comme ça
des milliers de 500 ballons mais jamais
vu autant ma vie comme ça et j'ai mis
tout ça sont sombres
j'étais dedans
et j'étais avec des copains et jeté avec
jean-philippe que vous connaissez j'ai
invité plein de copains et on a fait on
a fait une semaine on a fait n'importe
quoi et voilà bon j'étais jeune on ma
famille d'abord fils a
exceptionnellement fait vraiment chaud
c'est exceptionnel d'avoir invité j'ai
pris une suite était une somme colossale
et
tu deviens
pouvait régaler les copains s'en aller
du cac